all right so if you're looking for a fun
weekend brunch spot sdk at the
cosmopolitan it has you covered fully
let's welcome in executive chef stephen
hoffcroft
who's ready to show us what's on the
menu i
actually love sdk um and their brunch
is not just any brunch it's like a
social brunch you go in there you get
dressed up with your girls or your guys
or
all of them and you know it's you get
ready for good food and vibes
so let's ask the executive chef now what
exactly is
a social brunch can you explain that
how are you can you hear us
can you hear a chef we are not having
great luck with these guys today
i can hear you you can hear me how are
you hey
how are you let's talk about social
brunch what's on the menu
well i just wanted to tell you you and
everybody watching a little bit about
our brunch today um
we're we're not really uh trying to
recreate the wheel as far as it comes to
the food
right but uh we want to put a couple
more spokes in it
if that makes sense so i think the first
good example
is our uh our lobster benedict as you
can see that
what we're doing with that is instead of
you know using the traditional ham
we're going with a little spinach
and lobster and what goes better with
lobster than a poche
you know you got your little holiday
sauce here
that looks amazing right
oh my gosh the way we like this i don't
know
the way that we could uh dance this up
in my opinion
is with a little caviar right now you're
talking my language so these are a few
of my favorite things
caviar little poached eggs
and lobster of course paired with a
mimosa right for brian of course
you gotta have a bottomless buddy
married and who doesn't want the hoses
we're offering both we're offering both
for just 35
as we put this together here um i also
wanted to show you our french toast
a very cinnamon french toast very
traditional
very traditional but i'd like to put a
little cream cheese icing on it
and that's really bringing that one
together and then you have the chocolate
chef this all looks incredible i am
making my reservation
tonight so i will see you at sdk cosmo
very soon
i can't wait to have you come and see me